he picked up any new skills other than
Sagra fee I have I'm gonna tell you
something I'm gonna admit something to
you
and again you're millions of followers
and only to you guys I have become
really really adept shower cleaner now
like I'm talking about the kind of
person that you want to hire if you want
to make sure you can lick the floors of
your shower before you clean yourself in
them
my wife challenged me with with being
responsible for that part of our our
weekly cleaning routine and I took on
the challenge and I put on the gloves
I wear a bathing suit and I go in there
and I'm like I'm doing it as if to prove
a point I'm doing it as if to win
something like whatever shower cleaning
or Awards there is I've become really
really good everything I mean I have had
the brush to get the ground up I have
the mop I had those of those gloves that
you can order on like a shady website
that have like little they have like
little things coming out of them so you
can use the gloves to clean as well
their weekly neuronal axon off another
hundred percent using my Daniel Larusso
skills to get all the grime and crud off
oh my gosh I love you subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel
these don't make me keep going